ils ne veulent plus d'applaudissements
ni de médailles réunis devant l'hôpital
d'auxerre les soignons réclament
aujourd'hui une augmentation générale
des salaires 300 euros de plus par mois
pour revaloriser leur métier on a des
responsabilités on alterne les postes on
a des vies de familles qui sont quand
même chaotique par rapport à ce travail
est un minimum de 300 euros par mois ce
serait vraiment le minimum qu'on
pourrait accepter
en mars dernier le chef de l'état avait
promis un plan massif pour l'hôpital
mais pour l'instant les personnels
soignants ne voit toujours rien venir
aujourd'hui les syndicats réclament du
concret les revalorisations salariales
pour voir les catégories
professionnelles arrêter la fermeture
des lits arrêter la fermeture des
services
parce que c'est ça en fait à le cri de
je dirais de désespoir des hôpitaux
c'est qu'on a pas de moyens malgré le
port du masque obligatoire et les
mesures barrières
les habitants ont aussi répondu présent
comme ici à sens où 200 personnes se
sont réunies devant l'hôpital en
solidarité avec les soignants le corps
médical et mêmes paramédical a payé un
lourd tribut à cette gestion de crise
qui n'a pas été gérée par l'état
elle a reposé uniquement sur leurs
épaules faire de la journée nationale la
journée des héros aidants ne rien à
faire ce qu'ils veulent c'est soigné
dans de très bonnes conditions
et ça n'a pas été le cas depuis fin mai
des discussions ont débuté avec les
partenaires sociaux
première avancée le ministre de la santé
a promis que la rémunération des
soignants sera harmonisée avec celle des
autres pays européens